le bilan migratoire du Québec
par rapport à l'Ontario est
négatif. Mais le coût de la vie
et la COVID ont fait fléchir
cette tendance.
Jean-Sébastien Clo
♪ ♪ ♪
- Fin juin, la famille Chapman
sera québécoise.  Après 20 ans
passés dans la banlieue de
Toronto, Amélie qui est née sur
la Rive-Sud de Montréal, veut se
rapprocher de ses parents.
Ils vont donc quitter leur
petite maison de Burlington
située à plus de 50 kms de
Toronto, pour déménager ici,
moitié moins loin de Montréal,
à St-Mathieu-de-Beloeil.
Leur nouvelle maison sera
beaucoup plus moderne, plus
grande et entourée d'un plus
grand terrain.
AMÉLIE BASQUE-CHAPMAN
- C'est ça, on a vendu pour
1,250 million. Puis la maison
qu'on a achetée à St-Mathieu
nous a couté 1,77 million.
Mais on ne compare pas du tout
la même maison non plus.
C'est une maison qui correspond
à nos rêves, vraiment.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'immobilier coûte presque
deux fois moins cher à Montréal
qu'à Toronto. Un immense
avantage lorsqu'on déménage.
- C'est excitant parce que
je parle en français et en
anglais. Et les personnes au
Québec, elles parlent plus en
françaisfrançaisfrançaisfrançaie
je connais une langue davantage.
- Ça aurait été un projet qui
aurait été faisable avant
la COVID, mais encore beaucoup
plus facile avec la COVID parce
que mon travail maintenant nous
permet de rester à la maison.
- Coût de la vie et
télétravail : deux des facteurs
qui ont permis au Québec, pour
la première fois en 50 ans, de
finir 2021 avec un solde
migratoire positif face à
l'Ontario. L'an dernier,
19 493 Ontariens ont déménagé au
Québec, soit 787 de plus que
le nombre de Québécois partis en
Ontario. Tout un contraste avec
les dernières décennies alors
que le Québec perdait souvent
cinq à 10 mille personnes de
plus au profit de sa voisine.
MARIO POLÈSE,
professeur émérite INRS
- C'est une tendance qui s'est
amorcée depuis 5-6 ans. On voit
que le solde négatif diminue à
chaque année.
MARC DESORMEAUX, économiste
principal, Banque Scotia
- Le Québec, l'économie est très
forte. Elle vient juste de
compléter une croissance de
6,2 % en termes réels dans
l'année 2021. Le taux de
chômage, c'était à environ 4 %,
un des taux les plus bas au
Canada.
- L'Ontario, ajoute Marc
Desormeaux, vient d'ailleurs
d'enregistrer son plus grand
nombre de départs en 40 ans.
- 108 000 personnes ont quitté
l'Ontario pendant l'année civile
2021. Plusieurs gens décident de
déménager aux autres provinces :
aux provinces atlantiques.
La Colombie-Britannique
devientde plus en plus attirant.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Alors ça, c'est une de mes
photos d'un très grand projet
que je viens de compléter.
- Rita Leistner est une
photographe de Toronto qui a
quitté la ville Reine pour
Montréal en dernier. Elle y
songeait depuis longtemps et
la pandémie l'a amenée, elle
aussi, à faire le grand saut.
- J'espère que ça va aider
ma carrière. Absolument.
Et c'est peut être la première
considération dans toutes
mes décisions. C'est
ma photographie.
- Elle se sent bien dans son
grand appartement du Plateau
Mont-Royal qui est beaucoup plus
abordable qu'à Toronto.
Économiquement et
culturellement, Montréal à l'a
séduit.
- C'est la liberté, c'est
le français. C'est aussi...
une vibration à Montréal.
Différents... Je pense que c'est
plus social.
- Pendant longtemps, la
politique a fait fuir bien des
Québécois et fait peur à bien
des Ontariens. Après l'élection
du Parti québécois en 1976 par
exemple, pendant deux années
consécutive, le Québec avait
même perdu plus de 25 000
résidents au profit de
l'Ontario. Et environ 12 000
après le référendum de 1995.
Mais les temps ont changé.
- Même moi, de mon côté, vous
m'auriez demandé ça voilà
10 ans, puis je ne suis pas
certaine que je serais retournée
nécessairement parce que c'est
quelque chose qui était beaucoup
trop présent pour ma
personnalité.
- Ce n'est plus une crainte là,
c'est plus un facteur?
- Non, plus du tout.
- La personne de l'Ontario qui
est totalement bilingue
anglophone, et qui a peur du
français ne va pas déménager au
Québec. Mais la politique
dans le sens de la peur, de
la séparation et tout ça, non,
ça ne joue plus honnêtement.
- Mario Polèse s'attend à ce
qu'il y ait désormais un
meilleur équilibre migratoire
entre le Québec et l'Ontario.
- Oh! Cool.
- Rita Leistner continue
d'apprivoiser Montréal.
Elle voudrait y acheter
un multiplex et y demeurer
longtemps. L'avenir se vivra
sans doute aussi au Québec pour
la famille Chapman : Amélie
évoque déjà l'Université de ses
enfants. Mais il y a des choses
qui ne changeront pas.
- Are you leaving the Leafs to
be a Habs fan?
- Never!
(rire)
- Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Ca